mr President Collie excellence Kollegen
Exzellenzen meine Damen und Herren
vor mehr als fünf Monaten hat der
russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine Toten und
Zerstörung mit sich gebracht tut es
heute noch das ist ein Wendepunkt
ein Mitglied des Weltsicherheitsrats
verstößt gegen die
uno-kata und greift ein
Nachbarn an ein Land das Kernwaffen
abgetreten hat an Russland Russland
verstößt eindeutig gegen die
Zusicherungen aus dem Budapester
Memorandum seit dem 24 Februar hat
Russland wiederholt
du bist everything das Kernwaffen
gedroht und alles gefährdet etwas der
NVV der nicht verbreitungsvertrag in
fünf Jahrzehnten erreicht hat eine große
Mehrheit der Staaten hat die russische
Aggression und diese nuklearen Drogen
verurteilt wir haben es hier in diesem
Saal auf der Generalversammlung der
Vereinten Nationen im März getan als 141
Staaten Russlands Krieg verurteilt haben
ebenso den Beschluss Russlands den
Bereitschaftsgrad der eigenen
kernwaffenstreitkräfte zu erhöhen
es geht hier um Glaubwürdigkeit die
Glaubwürdigkeit derjenigen die sich
ernsthaft um eine nukleare Abrüstung
bemühen
diese Bemühungen und der nicht
verbreitungsvertrag
haben mittlerweile eine unsichere
Zukunft bekommen als ich mitgeteilt
hatte nach York zu reisen um hier
teilzunehmen fragt mich viele was machen
Sie denn hier das hat es denn für einen
Sinn für nukleare Abrüstung in solchen
Zeiten einzutreten nun weshalb sind wir
hier ich glaube die Antwort ist ganz
einfach
wir sind hier um die regelgestützte
Weltordnung zu verteidigen der NVV ist
nicht einfach ein Stück Papier der
verkörpert einige der grundlegenden
Verpflichtungen der Menschheit
Verhinderung eine Ausbreitung von
Kernwaffen
wir müssen dafür Sorge tragen dass
Kernwaffen die wieder eingesetzt werden
und auf das gemeinsame Ziel hinarbeiten
eine Welt ohne Atomwaffen zu erreichen
wenn wir uns bei dieser Konferenz
Treffen stehen wir an einer Wegscheide
aufgrund der Pandemie ist diese
Konferenz mittlerweile schon um zwei
Jahre verzögert worden
2015 hat die letzte
Überprüfungskonferenz stattgefunden wenn
wir die Fahne der nuklearen Abrüstung
heute einziehen sollten dann würden der
NVV und alles was dieser Vertrag
verkörpert verloren
wir lassen diese Pfade also flattern
nicht weil es eine einfache Aufgabe wäre
sondern weil es nötig ist
viel steht auf dem Spiel und viele von
ihnen haben es ja schon unterstrichen
viel steht auf dem Spiel für uns aber
noch mehr für die künftigen Generation
ich bin nicht naiv werden nicht alle
Hindernisse auf einer einzigen Konferenz
überwinden können aber wir können
standhalten und die Grundsätze
aufrechterhalten die im
Nichtverbreitungsvertrag verankert sind
das ist unsere dringliche Aufgabe
82 Jahre alter Mann hat mir letzten
Monat diese Botschaft überbracht ich
traf ihn Nagasaki in Japan
es ist ein Überlebender
der katastrophalen Atombomben Explosion
im August 1945 er sprach von dem
gleißenden Licht der Explosion von
seinen Angehörigen seinen Freunden die
sterben
weitere Angehörige und Freunde sterben
später noch Jahre später an Krebs
experience Dance seine Erfahrungen
stehen für den Schrecken von
hunderttausenden und ich schließe ein
viele Opfer von
Atomwaffentests in den Jahrzehnten
danach dieser Mann in einer gesagt die
sagte zu mir sorgen Sie dafür
dass die Menschheit nie wieder von
Atomwaffen gepeinigt wird und wenn wir
nur ein Zentimeter näher an dieses Ziel
gelangen können hier New York während
der nächsten Wochen dann wird es
wirklich jede Bemühung gelohnt haben
deshalb sind wir in diesem Monat hier
versammelt die wollen unseren Glauben
aufrechterhalten an eine
weltfriedensordnung ich sehe hierbei
vier Prioritäten für uns während wir
versuchen die Agenda des NVV
voranzubringen
zuerst einmal müssen wir die Gültigkeit
des Besitzstandes des NVV und das
Streichen unser Engagement betonen das
eine Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit und
bleibt die Grundlage für die ohne Welle
Unterstützung des NVV
russland hat die regelbasierte
Weltordnung angegriffen es ist umso
wichtiger jetzt vereinbarte Normen und
Prinzip recht aufrecht zu erhalten und
gegen Verstöße vorzugehen nun ist die
Zeit wo wir stark auftreten müssen wir
müssen zweitens die Gefahr der nuklearen
Eskalation vermindern und wieder den Weg
hin zur nuklearen Abrüstung beschreiten
zusammen mit unseren Partnern der
Stockholm Initiative und der Initiative
für nicht Verbreitung und Abrüstung
müssen wir viele Schritte verwirklichen
die jetzt oder kurzfristig angegangen
werden können
Transparenz über das Arsenal und
meinungsstärke Bemühungen um eine
bessere Kommunikation um eine Eskalation
zu vermeiden und dann ein neuer Dialog
über die Waffen der lichtengeneration
und künftige reduktionsmaßnahmen ich bin
überzeugt wenn wir wirklich es versuchen
dann können Fortschritte erreicht werden
aber und das ist auch die brutale
Realität all dies ist nur möglich wenn
alle Kernwaffenstaaten glaubwürdige
Schritt tun
heute
tut Russland das Gegenteil das
genetische Arsenal nimmt auch weiter zu
in diesem Zusammenhang begrüße ich die
Bereitschaft der Vereinigten Staaten die
heute bekundet worden ist einen neuen
rüstungscontrollrahmen zu schaffen für
das in new start-abkommen ein ehrlicher
Dialog ist hier nötig auch um bei der
nicht Verbreitung weiterzukommen und das
ist nun mein dritter Punkt
das safeguard System der iaio ist die
größte Leiste im Rahmen des nicht
verbreitungsvertrags wir müssen dieses
Sicherungssystem also stärken
der Kampf gegen die Verbreitung muss
unseren ganzen Einsatz
nötig machen
das iranische Atomprogramm ist hier für
uns ein Anlass zu großer Bedeutung
degran hat für viele nukleäre
Aktivitäten keine Rechtfertigung
kein nicht
kernhaften Staat braucht bis auf 60%
angereichertes Uran du als Beispiel
das ist also anders die große Besorgnis
wir fordern also die Iran auf wie viele
Kollegen vor mir und zwar mit aller
Dringlichkeit das Paket anzunehmen dass
für das atomabkommen geschnürt worden
ist alles liegt auf dem Tisch wir
sollten diese Chance nutzen solange die
Möglichkeit besteht
Konferenz sollte auch Einheit zeigen
gegenüber der Verletzung durch
das nordkoreanische Kernwaffenprogramm
die brauchen also eine
de nuklearisierung der koreanischen
Halbinsel und die Umsetzung aller
einschlägigen Resolutionen des
Weltsicherheitsrats
schließlich sollten wir uns bemühen die
Polarisierung zu überwinden und das
gleiche Gewicht den Positionen der
Staaten im Norden wie im Süden in der
nvv-gemeinschaft geben vor diesem
Hintergrund
hässlich seid mein Land Deutschland
beschlossen als Beobachter aufzutreten
bei der ersten
Konferenz
des Vertrages über das Verbot von
Kernwaffen das wird zwar unsere
Rechtsposition zu den Vertrag nicht
ändert wir möchten aber für ein bisschen
Dialog
beitragen und die humanitären Folgen von
Kernwaffen mildern wir wollen Opfern
helfen oder
Gebiete wieder renaturieren die durch
Kernwaffen Versuche zerstört worden sind
es geht um die Exposition gegenüber
nuklearen Risiken ionisierende
Strahlungen und Folgen auf Frauen und
Kinder sind hier besonders zu erwähnen
verlangen dass wir auch gender sensible
Maßnahmen ergreifen in diesem Bereich
der Präsident liebe Kollegen liebe
Freunde
als der nvv-vertrag vor mehr als 50
Jahren in Kraftrad hatten viele Zweifel
an den Möglichkeiten bei allen
Schwierigkeiten ist hierdurch eine
stabilere Weltordnung geschaffen worden
und ein friedlicheres Leben für eine
ganze Generation
die heutigen Aufgaben zeigen aber dass
diese Erfolge abhängig sind vom guten
Glauben und den gemeinsamen blühungen
aller Vertragsparteien
diese Erfolge sind auf uns angewiesen
hängt von uns ab
die Aussichten auf eine erfolgreiche
Überprüfungskonferenz mögen geringer
sein als je zuvor aber es steht einfach
zu viel auf dem Spiel um aufzugeben
jetzt ist es an der Zeit das zu
verteidigen was die Kation vor uns
aufgebaut hat nun ist die Zeit dafür
einzutreten dass wir eine friedliche
Weltordnung bekommen danke schön
[Applaus]